In this course, you will learn
how to create a full stack
application using MongoDB for
the database, Java and Spring
Boot for the back end and react
for the front end. Farhan Hasin
Chaudry teaches the back
end section of this course. And
Gavin Lon teaches the front end
section of the course. Both
these instructors are very
experienced and have created
many popular courses. The
project featured in this course
is a great example of the
creation of a separation of
concerns between the client code
and the server code. By
implementing a loosely coupled
architecture. These two parts
implemented using different
technologies can evolve in
parallel and independently from
one another. So let's start
learning from Farhan. Hello,
everyone. Welcome to the Java
with MongoDB course on the freeCodeCamp YouTube channel.
I am for Han has ensured three
one of the instructors in this
course and I will teach you all
about developing a back end API
using Java EE Spring Boot, and
MongoDB. The other half of the
course will be taught by
Katherine lOn. Hi, I'm Gavin
lOn. I'm a full stack developer
and have over 20 years
experience working as a software
developer. In this course, I'm
going to be playing the role of
a front end developer. And my
responsibility will be to
demonstrate building a front end
using React js. The Spy
application that we are going to
create will use HTTP GET
requests to appropriately
retrieve data from a remote
server through communicating
with the relevant API's
endpoints. And HTTP POST
requests will also be made to
the relevant endpoints to
appropriately save data on the
server side. Of course, our data
will be stored within a MongoDB
database on the relevant remote
server. So without further ado,
let's jump in and start working
on our API. In the beginning of
the course, you will have to
download two new software's from
the internet. The first one
being Java Development Kit, or
JDK. If you already have JDK
installed on your system, you
should be good to go with that.
But just in case you do not have
it installed, I'd suggest you
navigate to
oracle.com/java/technologies/downloads
The link will be in description.
Once you have landed on the
download page for Java, you may
find multiple versions of JDK
available as of the recording of
this course there. The latest
version is Java 19. And the
latest LTS version is Java 17.
lts C stands for long term
support and JDK 17 will receive
updates until September 2020 For
JDK 19 On the other hand, will
receive updates only until March
2023 and will be superseded by
JDK 20. In many cases, when you
are deploying a Java application
on a production server, it's
suggested that you use LTS
release for better stability.
And for this course I will stick
to Java 17 Since that's the
latest LTS. Now depending on
when you're watching this
course, there may be a new LTS
release so feel free to download
and install that. So I've
switched to Java 17 And since I
am on Windows, I will go to
windows and the 64 bit
installer. As you can see, it's
only 150 2.85 megabytes and
depending on your internet
connection, you it may take a
few minutes to download.
Once you have downloaded the
installer, make sure you have
installed it on your system like
any other software you have done
before. And since the
instruction is so
straightforward, I will not
spend a lot of time showing you
the entire process.
After you have finished
installing JDK on your computer,
open up your terminal window and
write Java C space double dash
barsha.
And if you don't get any errors
from this command, this is a
positive sign and as it says
Java C 17 point 0.5 which
indicates that I have
successfully installed seven
point 17 point 0.5 version of
the JDK. Now Java C is the short
for Java compiler which you may
or may not have already guessed.
Apart from this command, you can
also use Java double dash
version to check the version of
your Java Runtime Environment
and as you can see it says 17
point 0.5 lts which means we are
good to go.
Since you have successfully
installed the jdk on your
computer Next up you will need a
good code editor or IDE. When it
comes to Java, there are plenty
of options out there. You can go
into Eclipse or maybe configure
Visual Studio code. But I would
suggest that you go with
IntelliJ IDEA. Now the people at
Jet
Ian's are known for making
really good IDE s and when it
comes to Java IntelliJ IDEA is
pretty much the industry
standard.
Although the ultimate version
can cost you some money, there
is also a free version available
by the name of Community
Edition. Or to download IntelliJ
IDEA, navigate to
jetbrains.com/ideas/download.
Again, the link could be in
description and look for the
Community Edition. This is the
flag download button here. And
depending on your platform, ie
Windows, Mac OS or Linux, you
may get a different format. For
example, if you're on Mac OS,
you will get a DMG image. And if
you're on Linux, you will get a
tar file. So I'm on Windows and
I want to download the exe
installer and not the zip one.
So I'll select exe, and then hit
download. Now the IDE is a bit
larger than the JDK in size at
649 megabytes. But again,
depending on your internet
connection, it may take a few
minutes to download. Once you
have downloaded the software,
please go ahead and install it
like any other software that you
have done before.
Congratulations on you're
getting the JDK and IntelliJ
IDEA getting installed. Next up,
you will need an account at
MongoDB Atlas. Now you may or
may not already know that
MongoDB Atlas is a platform from
MongoDB themselves that allows
you to spin up MongoDB servers
on the cloud.
So in order to use MongoDB
Atlas, you will have to maybe
get to
mongodb.com/atlas/database.
Again, the link will be in
description and use the Sign In
button.
Once in the sign in page, you
can either use your Google or
GitHub account to log in or you
can sign up with your other
email addresses for a new
account. Now, I already have an
account on MongoDB Atlas. So I
will just use those credentials
to log into my account off
screen. As you can see, I have
successfully logged into my
account. And For first time
users, you may have to set up a
new organization of sore just
just put any name as the
organization name and you should
be good to go. Since we are
using these for just our
development purposes, it's okay
to just use any data that you
have. So once you have set up
your organization, you can
create new projects. So I will
hit the New Project button here.
And I have to give my project a
name. Now since you are creating
an API that is related to movie
I'll just call my movie API. And
hit Next
I will just go ahead and create
project since I don't have any
other member to add.
Extra now we are inside our
movie API project. And we are
ready to create a new database.
So you can use the builder
Database button here to create a
new MongoDB database on MongoDB
Atlas. So just go ahead and
click this button.
And there are three different
categories there is server list
there is dedicated and there is
shared. Now for development
purposes, our shared server
should be fine and it's
completely free. But if you're
working on an application that
that has some user and have some
real life usage, you may go with
dedicated Serverless is
something else and maybe we can
talk about it in a different
course some other day. So select
Share, and hit create.
Okay, next up, they will ask you
about which provider you want to
use, I always go with AWS. Since
AWS has a server on Mumbai,
which is near Bangladesh and has
the lowest ping for me, but if
you like you can go with Google
Cloud or Azure. Now select
whatever region is the nearest
to you to make sure that you are
getting the lowest amount of
being possible. Next, you can
choose a dear.
Again, for free usage, we use
the aim zero sandboxed here it
will give us 512 megabytes of
RAM which is more than enough
for our usage we will have a
very small amount of data to be
honest. And then next step there
are additional settings you
don't have to touch them and the
cluster name. Now you can
customize the cluster name if
you
Wish but I will just leave it as
cluster zero since I like it
that way, then hit Create
cluster
Okay, next up, you will have to
create a new user for this
cluster. You can also use an SSH
certificate, but I will just go
with the old trusty username
thing. So I will name my
usernames Solid Snake since I'm
a Metal Gear Solid fan, but you
can name it anything you want.
Now, when it comes to password,
make sure you are always
choosing a very strong password
and not ones that are easy to
remember. Use a password manager
maybe but always use hard to
guess passwords. So I will just
use the auto generated secure
password.
And I will also make sure that I
am copying my password to the
clipboard, since I will be
needing this later on. But then
hit the Create User button.
It shows Solid Snake and the
password.
And finally, you will have to
set up some IP access list. So
the way it works, once you have
set up a new database, you will
have to allow a set number of IP
addresses that can access that
server. You know opening up a
database server to the world is
not a good idea. Security wise,
so you should always use your
current IP address here.
But since this is just a course,
and we are using this database
for development, I will open up
the server for all the IP
addresses out there. And to do
that, you can write 0.0 dot 0.0
slash zero and in the
description, you can just write
a view
and hit Add Entry. See that
that's there. And then click on
finish and close.
Okay, they will congratulate you
and whatnot Hi quickstart guide
Yes, go to database
disclose it.
Excellent. Now we have a
database up and running on
MongoDB Atlas. And we can use
this database ganache to eat
read and write data from and to
eat.
And using just like a local
database that you may have used
in your computers, you see
MongoDB Atlas is a very
beautiful service. I have used
it for development as well as
for production in the past and I
have never had any bad
experiences with it.
So next up, you can use some
sort of database client to
connect to this database, maybe
something like MongoDB compass,
so you can go ahead and click on
Connect.
And MongoDB will give you
multiple options that you can
choose from. So first, you can
connect to your database server
using MongoDB shell, you can
connect to the MongoDB server
using your application that
you're working on right now, you
can connect to MongoDB server
using MongoDB compass which is
MongoDB own graphical user
interface for working with
databases and I will just show
you that. Finally you can also
connect using VS code. And let's
be connect using MongoDB compass
for now.
And I do not have MongoDB
compass on my computer. So I
will be Windows 64 bit
and I will just hit download
compass.
Once you have downloaded and
installed MongoDB compass on
your computer, you can start the
software from your start menu or
desktop. Once you start MongoDB
compass it looks something like
this where they are giving you
the option to connect to a new
database by using this kind of
URI. Now where do you get this
URI. If you come back to MongoDB
Atlas, you will see that they
are actually giving that URI
right here.
Just use this copy button to
copy the entire URI and go back
to MongoDB compass. Now remove
this localhost URI from here and
paste it yours. Now as you can
see it says MongoDB plus SRV
Benue username, followed by a
colon and then it's looking for
a password right. So what we are
going to do, we will use the
password that we created earlier
and paste it in here. And then
we'll leave everything as is and
we
He can say Save and connect. You
can name it anything. So I'm
naming it V Avi,
you can change its color if you
want to, and say Save and
connect.
Okay, so it took a few seconds.
And as you can see, we have
successfully connected to our
moving API cluster. Now, as you
can see, there are two
databases, one of them is called
admin. And the other one is
called Local. Now, we do not
have to do anything with these,
these come by default with all
the clusters out there. So just
leave them be and we will create
new databases very soon. To
create a new database, you can
always go and click this plus
sign.
And inside database name,
let's put b
What really, let's call it
movie,
API deep.
And inside collection them. Now
if you're new to databases, like
like MongoDB, or document based
database, you may or may not
know that collections are like
tables in case of relational
database systems. So in
something like MySQL, or Oracle
database system, you have
databases, and inside those
databases, you have tables. Now,
in case of MongoDB, and other
non relational databases, you
have the database name first,
and then collections. For
example, in our cases, we will
have a collection of movies
where we will save information
about different movies. So we
can say movies and in create
database. So as you can see, we
have a new database sitting here
movie API dv, and there is a
collection called movies. So
right now, there is no data at
all.
Now in order to work with our
API, it would be convenient if
we have a bunch of data in our
collections. And if you navigate
to github.com/ach, si n ch y,
which is my username and slash
movies, you will get the entire
code for this API already
written. And inside that
repository, you will see a
folder that says underscore
data. Now inside this folder,
there is a JSON file that you
can use as a source of data for
the collection we have just
created. So I would suggest you
go into this JSON file, then
select raw,
and then hit CTRL S and say this
JSON file somewhere on your
computer.
So once you have downloaded the
file, you can then import it to
your collection. To do so, come
back to MongoDB compass. And
while you have the movies
collection selected, you can
click on this Import Data button
or this Add Data button. Then
select Import File. And our
format is JSON. And we'll select
the file from our downloads and
movies dot JSON. And you can
also take a stop on errors, then
hit import, wait a few moment.
It done. And viola, we have the
information of n different
movies on our database. So as
you can see,
each of this movie is a document
Okay, as it as it says documents
then. So inside the collection,
each of this movie are a single
document. And what do we have
inside these documents? Well, we
have an ID we have the IMDB ID
for this title whose inputs, we
have the release date, which is
a string, we have the link for a
trailer on YouTube. Then we have
an array of genres. So this
particular movie belongs to five
genres. Then we have a link to
our poster.
We have linked to end backdrops
that will be later utilized in
the front end application as you
can see, finally, we have an
empty array for review IDs. Now,
this will come into play later
on in this course, so just be
patient with me for now.
Okay, so one thing that I'd like
to mention right here I am using
the tmdb.org API for this
images are TMDb is an excellent
website. And they provide a free
to use API for developers as
long as you are giving them
credit. So I do, so I will be
using the API for portraying the
images. So now that we have
created a new database on
MongoDB. Plus, we have set up a
new collection, we have imported
some data into it, it's time for
us to start working on our API
code.
Now the first step to writing
our API using Spring Boot, is to
initialize it first. To do that,
navigate to start.spring.io.
Again, links will be in the
description. And let's start
initializing our project. First,
we'll have to pick a programming
language, which is going to Java
in this case. But if you're
familiar with groovy or Kotlin,
you may go with them, then we
will have to pick a project
autumn build automation tool.
And the initializer supports
both Gradle and Maven which are
not the most popular build
automation tool for Java, I am
doing with Maven, simply because
I have more experience working
with this then Gradle. Next up,
picking up the Spring Boot
version 3.0. Point one is the
latest stable version. And we
will be using that throughout
the course. But if you would
like to try out some more
bleeding edge features, you can
use the snapshots once you have
become more familiar with the
framework.
After that, we will have to fill
up the project metadata.
Now the group is usually written
in reverse domain format. So for
example, my website is Farhan
dot Dev. And I would like to
name my group date dot for her.
So if you do not have a domain
of yourself, you can name it
anything you like, as long as
that package group is not
referring to someone else's
project
nextra that artifact name, the
artifact name is simply the name
of the project. So in this case,
I will be putting movies in
here, but feel free to call in
something else if you feel like
that.
Next there is a description
field and you can put something
like
after that, we will have to pick
up packaging for now java is a
very popular packaging format
for Java and it stands for Java
archive wire. On the other hand,
it stands for web archive. And
you may think that will wire is
more suited for this project
since it's going to be a web
application, right? Maybe yes,
but since jar is more widely
used than where I will be going
with.
Next speaking the Java version,
obviously, I'm going to pick 17,
since we just spent quite some
time setting up Java 17 on our
computers. Once you are done
with the left column, let's
focus on the right column. In
this one, you will have to pick
the dependencies that you would
like to use in your project. So
use this add button, and you
will be presented with a long,
very long list of dependencies.
And the first one that we are
going to use in our project is
Lombok, it's an additional
library that saves you from
writing a lot of boilerplate
code. And you will see what I
mean in action very soon. So
please be patient. Since we are
going to pick multiple
dependencies, you will have to
keep pressing either Ctrl on
Windows or Linux and command on
Mac. In fact, it says here,
right on the right corner press
Control to multiple apps. Okay
for multiple ads, so I'm
pressing down on control and I
will pick Lombok
Lombok has been picked. Next up
spring web.
And finally,
let's see.
No nada SQL under no SQL, we
will need Spring Data MongoDB
Yeah, that's that's pretty much
it. You can also search for
things here, for example, dev
tools, and let's add that as
well. Once done, you can exit
out of this selector by pressing
Escape on your keyboard and have
a look at the list of
dependencies and make sure you
have the
Everything. Now there are other
dependencies that you may learn
about later on, such as the
reactive web,
or Graph QL, or rest
repositories or something like
maybe spring security, which can
be used for authentication and
authorization. There is more to
client if you're into auth, and
things like that. But since we
will not be getting into
authentication and authorization
in this course, we will stay out
from the
get go. Once you are happy with
the configuration in this
initializer to go ahead and
click Generate.
It will take a few seconds to
generate the SIP archive, and it
will start downloading
automatically. Once downloaded,
you have to extract these movies
dot zip or whatever you have
named your artifact dot c file
to somewhere in your computer
easily accessible.
After you have extracted the
downloaded zip file somewhere on
your computer, you can go ahead
and open it in your favorite IDE
or code editor. In my case, it's
IntelliJ IDEA and I have
extracted my project on my D
drive.
So I will go ahead and click on
open first.
Then come to the folder where I
have extracted the project and I
will pick it up.
Okay, so IntelliJ IDEA will ask
whether you actually just this
project or not. This is a safety
feature to save you from
malicious code from running on
your computer. So since we are
writing it ourself, I just pick
trust project.
And give ideas some time for
resolving all the dependencies.
And once it's ready, you are
free to go.
Let's try to understand the
project structure first. So
ignore the dot env and folder,
it's managed by Maven. So you
don't have to worry about it
right now. There is the src
folder, which is short for
source. And it will contain your
program source code as well as
the test code. So we are not
going to write any tests. So
let's jump into the main folder.
So inside main there is Java and
resources, we will have to work
inside both of these
directories. So let's go inside
Java. And as you can see, here
is the name of our project after
400 movies, it it may be
different in your computer
depends on what you have chosen
in the initializer. But it
should be something similar.
Then there is a class that
represents your applications
names. So since I have named my
artifact movies, it says movies
application, which is pretty
appropriate to be honest.
In other movies application
class contains around 10 lines
of code minus spaces in between.
So let's try to understand what
it's doing. The first line is
actually declaring a package
which is pretty self
explanatory. Next, there are two
input statements. The first one
is a class called Spring
application. Now this particular
class contains a method called
Run. And to start your Spring
application, you actually have
to call this run method, and
then pass your application class
to it. And then you can also
pass some command line arguments
which we are not going to touch
the second import a statement
imports like the Spring Boot
application annotation. So
annotations in Java are usually
used to let the compiler know
about what this class does.
So other than this class, there
is more or less nothing inside
this package. So let's try to
run our application and see if
we can we can have anything on
our browser. Okay.
So you can actually click on
this play button, besides the
main method to run the program
or this class play button, or
this play button at the top.
Let's use this one.
Okay, so if your IDE says Lombok
requires enabled annotation
processing, just go ahead and
click on Enable annotation
processing and it should be
fine.
Now, if you look at the
terminal, you will see that
there is a nice arc that says
the spring the springs version
and there's bunch of logs and
There is an exception. That
exception states that the
application is failing to
connect to any MongoDB database
at all. Which is true, since we
have not let the application
know about our, our cluster, our
username, our passwords and
things like that application
cannot connect to our MongoDB
database. Now, it's fine if you
want to leave this error here.
Or if you want to get rid of
this error,
you can just first stop that
application.
Open the POM dot XML file, which
contains a list of all the
different dependencies that we
are using.
And then look for
MongoDB.
It should be here somewhere
yeah, there you go. Dependency
artifact the Spring Boot starter
data MongoDB. So just highlight
the entire thing. And press ctrl
and the forward slash which will
comment this out.
Then right click on form dot XML
and then go to Maven
and go to reload project
now try to run the application
once again.
No your whatsoever.
So if you look at the logs, it
will say that Tomcat started on
port 8080 Tomcat is actually an
web server that will serve as
the web server the development
web server for our application.
Now, you'd have to switch to a
web browser to see the
application in action. So let's
do that.
And then you can navigate to
localhost
88080.
There you go. Now it says
whitelabel error page, that's
fine. At least we know that the
application is booting up and we
are actually hitting the API
itself. And not just some other
page when what is zero states is
that there is no endpoint at
all. So although we have an API,
there is no API to hit. I hope
that makes sense. Now let's go
back to our code and try to
write our first endpoint.
But after where it says the
Spring Boot application,
we will say
Rest Controller.
It's another annotation that
lets
the framework note that this
class is actually a REST API
controller and not just another
class. Then inside this class,
you will have to say
get mapping.
And next we'll have to create a
new method called public. And
the return type will be string.
And the name of the method can
be anything but let's just call
it API index for now. Because
this is the
route endpoint or or list, let's
call it API route.
And we can say return.
Have no or
I know have our programs are
boring, but it's essential, you
know.
So this gate mapping and
notation to each, what it does,
is that it lets the framework
know that this method right
here, API route, is a good
endpoint. So if I put a bracket
right here, and then inside,
I'll say slash just a forward
slash. Let's stop our
application and run it again.
Let's see if there are any
errors.
looks fine to me. Let's switch
to our web browser
and do a refresh. As you can
see, it says hello world. Let me
just increase the zoom level a
bit. So you can
tell alright.
Now instead of putting a forward
slash here, if I say for say
slash route,
rerun the application
you will see that the whitelabel
error page is back. But if you
navigate to slash route, you
will see
Hello world. I hope this makes
sense. Although DCS are valid
eight point, we are not going to
make our API like this, we will
actually divide our application
into separate layers, there will
be a service layer, there will
be a data access layer, and
there will be an API layer. So
let's go forward and get rid of
this code and restart to put
together our movies API.
Now, in my opinion, the first
logical step would be to
configure the database for our
application so that we can
successfully connect to the
MongoDB cluster that we have set
up previously, and talk to it.
To do so, open up the src folder
right here, go inside main,
go inside resources, and open
the file that says application
dot properties.
Now, in this file, you will have
to write the different
application properties that is
related to your project. For
example, right now, we are
trying to configure our MongoDB
dependency.
And to do that, you will have to
write
spring dot data dot Mongo DB dot
database
equals to the name of the
database. I hope you remember
that we named our database
something like movies API dB. So
we will write movies API dB,
and next spring
dot data dot Mongo DB dot URI.
Now in here, you will have to
actually write that URI to your
MongoDB cluster like you did
with Compass.
I have my URL already copied to
my clipboard. And I hope that
you have saved it somewhere
safe. Like I said in the
beginning of the course that I
will just go ahead and paste it
right there.
And you can get rid of this
slash test thing. And the last
slash, and it should be fine.
Okay, so
our application should be able
to connect to our database. Now
to test it out. Let's go back to
POM dot XML. Let's remove the
comments.
And then let's start our
application.
Oh, see, we have forgot to
reload our project. And the IDE
is actually suggested me to load
the map and changes. So I can
just click this button or you
can go ahead and right click and
go to Melbourne and reload
project. Let's use this button
and see if it works fine or not.
Of course it does. Let's run the
application.
And now the Euro is called. And
actually it says some things
about the MongoDB driver
cluster. And this is a positive
sign. If it failed to connect to
the database itself, it would
have screamed at us and whatnot.
But thankfully, it's fine.
Now, if you have worked with any
applications, specifically web
applications in the past, you've
may already know that putting
sensitive data like this in a
file that's going to be in your
GitHub repository is not safe at
all.
Instead, what you should be
doing is putting all these
things in a dot env file. So we
can right click on Resource, go
to new and create a dot env file
for ourselves.
And we can write down a few
properties here.
Mongo database, then Mongo user,
then Mongo
password,
finally, Mongo
cluster.
Now you can go back to the
properties file, and you can
start moving these values one by
one to your env file. So this is
going to be the Mongo database.
Next up the Mongo user name
which is
Solid Snake in my case, good
among but then Mongo password.
Finally, the cluster.
And I sometimes like to put them
inside quotes, this makes sure
that if one of the passwords or
username or clusters contain
some special characters in them,
it would not
disturb the order of things. So
I like to put this quotation
marks around each fabs. Okay,
now we have our env file ready
to go, what I would suggest that
you create another env file,
simply called dot env, dot
example,
for later reference references
then make sure you open up the
dot Git ignore file. And as you
can see, the Initialize project
actually comes with a pretty
good Git ignore file already.
But we'll have to add a few
things for ourselves, right. So
you will say, you can actually
copy this thing from here and
paste it and say,
in the white.
Yeah. And then you say.in With
this will make sure that you do
not accidentally commit that dot
env file into your repository
and open up your database to the
word.
Now, the only problem with this
spring is that spring doesn't
support reading dot env files
out of the box.
So what we'll need is we
actually need to install
a new dependencies to our
project. And I would like to
take this opportunity to show
you how you can add new
dependencies to the project
later on. So I'll switch back to
my browser. I'll open up a new
tab and I will search for
Maven
dependencies, something like
that. Yeah. And here is Maven
repository.
Then let's search for something
along the line spring. Dog
Ian's.
Yeah, I am referring to this one
by Paul Suarez. I apologize if I
have pronounced his name wrong.
Let's select this one. And we
can see that it says this spring
plugins 1.0. And it says Central
and whatnot. Okay, so the name
of the thing is made up Paul
Torres spring dot EMV. So as you
can guess this is his group,
group name and thesis, the name
of the artifact or the or the
project itself. So we can go
back to our code. Let's open up
POM dot XML. And inside the
dependencies bar, make sure you
are inside dependencies and not
outside somewhere here. After
the last dependency, we will
create a new one.
So it is a dependency.
And the ID helps us by auto
completing this. And we will say
that the group ID is mi dot
Paul
is he h, w A are set just to
make sure you can always copy
from here.
No one's going to judge you for
that. And then name of the
artifact which is spring dot E
and
now it's not strictly necessary
to define a version as well. But
you can do so by saying
version and then put maybe the
latest from two point 5.4
by one. Yeah.
So that's it, let's reload
Maven.
And yet now our project has the
ability to use the spring dot
env artifact and three dot env
fights. Let's go back to our
application properties and
replace these hard coded values
with our dot env references. To
do so open up the resources and
we need the
env so Mongo database Mongo user
Mongo password, okay?
So you will first have to get
rid of this value and then start
with $1 sign
and curly braces. And inside the
set of curly braces, you will
see say e NV dot
Mongo.
What do they call it? Database?
Yeah, Mongo database, and you
can kind of copy it from here
then
replace Solid Snake by Mongo
user.
And then they should be Mongo
password.
But sore tricked.
Yes. And finally a cluster.
Cluster Yes. Does this mean?
Okay, we can ignore this typo.
And if you want Singapore, you
can actually come to this
problem step and have a look at
what are what's the ID is
complaining about. So the
annuals property, let's just
ignore them from now.
Which ones per year? Yeah. Okay,
let's ignore these for now. And
the typos. Okay, Mongo is not a
typo.
Except let's try running our
application once again and see
if our env file has taken any
effect or not.
So as it turns out, our MongoDB
connection is fine, which means
the end file has been read
successfully. And we have
successfully secured our
confidential information from
going out into the world. Now
you, you don't have to write
everything inside an env file,
you can actually use this en v
dot name of the variable
notation to access any
environment variable variable in
your operating system. But I
will not get into that anymore
since we don't need it. Let's go
ahead and get along with our
project.
Now in our application, there
are two types of data that we
are going to work with. First
there are the movies and then
there are the reviews. So we
will need to first create two
separate classes for
representing these two entities
in our application. So first,
let
left click on your project name
new and Java class let's call it
movie.
And inside this movie, we will
first have to annotate this
class as a document.
This will let the framework note
that this class sheet presents
each document in the movies
collection.
And we will also define the name
of the collection here movies.
Then inside here we will have a
bunch of private data. So
private
object ID ID this will represent
the ID of this movie and private
IMDb ID sorry,
string
IMDb ID which will represent the
IMDB ID of this movie. And
preferred
string, title,
private string
release date
for private string
Schadler link this will be a
link to the YouTube page for the
trailer
private is string poster a link
to the image on the internet
private list string this will be
the genres because there can be
multiple genres of a single
movie. And these lists class
need to be imported
at Java util
by any private list string
and
this will be the backdrops now
this backdrop images will
actually be used in the front
end application as you will see
later. Let's just quickly jump
to MongoDB compass and make sure
that we have indeed written all
the necessary properties for
this class.
So as you can
Let's see we have written high D
IMDb ID title yes released a
trailer link genres poster,
backdrops, air review ID. So you
you, we will add review IDs, a
few moments later.
Now, we will have to also
annotate this ID field
as an actual ID, this will lead
the framework know that
this property should be treated
as the unique identifier for
each movie inside the database.
Okay, apart from this we will
also need getters setters that
do is string methods and some
constructors. So instead of
writing out getters setters to a
string for each of these private
properties, we can just say
at the read data, and this is
one of the annotations that
comes from the Lombok project.
And it takes care of all those
different gators setters and two
string methods. Next, we'll also
add all args constructor, this
is basically an addition for
creating a constructor that
takes all this private field as
argument finally, no args
constructor, which means another
constructor that takes no
parameters whatsoever.
Okay, next, let's create the
reviews. So Java class
reveal,
it's the same deal.
So this will be document
and the collection name will be
G fields. Now, we haven't
created this collection yet. But
the application itself has the
ability to create new
collections. So we don't have to
worry about that. We'll add data
just like before.
All
args constructor, Nords.
constructor, and then
there will be two private
properties for a strong private
object ID.
ID, this will be the ID in this
case.
And then private
review body
just just body string body.
Okay, so as you may have already
seen in the database design,
that each of these movies has an
array of this review, and we
haven't yet added this this area
of reviews to the movie model
yet. So to do that, we will go
back to the movie class,
go near the end and say
private
least
review.
Review IDs. Okay, so it matches
this name review IDs, and the
hall that our names are matching
as well. Yes. Now if you write
it like this, this will be an
embedded relationship. So all
the reviews that are related,
this movie will be added to this
list of reviews. Now this is
completely fine. In fact, if you
are modeling a one to many
relationship, such as one movie
can have many reviews, this is
the way to go. But since I'm
trying to demonstrate some of
the features of Springboard
MongoDB data, I will show you a
nifty annotation right here. So
I will say
document reference.
So this will cause the database
to store only the IDs of the
review. And the views will be in
a separate collection. So this
is called
manual reference relationship.
And there are some other ways to
create relationships in MongoDB.
I would suggest that you search
them up on Google or MongoDB
sufficient documentation and
read about them on your leisure.
It will give you a lot of
context. So now that we have our
movie and review models ready to
go, we can go ahead and start
writing on controllers. So I'd
right click on
my packet then a Java class.
This will be called Movie
controller.
And this is our first official
day
API controller that we are
writing in this API. Previously,
we wrote a simple controller in
our movies application class,
but this time, it's going to be
a bit different. So first, we
will need to annotate this class
as a Rest Controller.
And instead of mapping it to
localhost 8080, I want to make
it sorry.
Mapping request mapping, I want
to make it map to slash API
slash v1 slash movies. So any
requests to slash API slash v1
slash movies endpoint will be
handled by this particular
controller. Next, I will create
a new gate method. So I will say
get mapping. And then
public.
Let's return string for now.
All movies,
and then we can return
all movies.
OK, let's try to run our program
and see if it works or not.
Let's hit the play button.
Okay, it's compiled fine. Let's
go back to our browser. And here
localhost 8080 slash route.
We will get rid of fruit and say
slash API, slash V one, slash
movies.
And it works. Now although it's
okay to return these strings
from this endpoint, it's better
to return a response
entity I'll show you why in a
minute. So this is a generic
pipe. So we'll say string.
And then instead of returning or
returning, and instead of
returning all of this like this,
we will say,
new response entity of type is
String. And this is the value.
Then HTTP status dot O.
HTTP status dot okay means 200.
Let's read on this program.
Refresh, and it works just as
expected. Now, you may not see
any difference there. But if you
go back to your terminal
and say, curl, I HTTP localhost
8080 slash API slash v1 slash
movies, you will see we are
indeed returning the 200
response code.
This comes in handy when working
on a front end application and
any REST API out there should
return proper status codes.
Since we have the movie model
right here,
let's try to use it and pull
some data from the database.
For that, we will need a service
class as well as a repository
class. So let's create the
repository first, because that's
the shorter one. So it's a Java
class. And we'll select
interface because repositories
are of type interface. And then
we'll say movie in repository.
Yeah, now this interface will
extend
Mongo repository. This is the
generic type. And we will have
to let it know what type of data
we are dealing with. So movie,
and we'll also need to let it
know what type of ID we're
dealing with, which will be
object
ID, there you go. That's all for
this interface, you will need to
unnoted this interface as a
repository. So that framework
knows that this is a repository.
And then let's create a service
class which will be movie
service.
And this class will not extend
anything, you will just need to
annotate as service.
Now, inside this class, we will
write the database access
methods. So the first one will
be public
Get on movies.
Let's just name it all movies.
And let's just change our
controller method name to get on
this because since it's a get
mapping, we're saying get all
modes.
And the return type will be list
of what will return a list of
movie from this method.
Now, inside the service class,
you will need a reference of the
repository to do that you will
say
movie repository
it will be a private field.
And its name will be movie
repository.
Now if you know Java, you may
know that you will have to first
initialize this bit of code, you
will either have to initialize
it using a constructor, or you
can just use auto wire an
audition what this will cause it
will let the framework know that
we want the framework to
instantiate this class here for
us, okay.
Let's go inside the method now.
And we will say return
move the repository dot find all
these find all method is
described inside the Mongo
repository class. As you can
see, it says right here find all
and it will return and least of
the data type that we have
passed right here certainly
stock movie. So that's our
service class right there. And
then let's go back to our
controller, we will need a
reference to our service class.
So we will say private
movie service movie surface. And
just like we did in the service
class, we will auto wired the
service class. Since it has the
service and audition right here,
we will set auto wire.
Excellent. And it's also
now inside the good old movies.
Instead of returning a response
entity of type string
change it to list
so we are returning a response
entity of type list movie.
Then inside the method, we will
have to write return
movie service.of movies
new response entity
of type list
movie
and inside movie service drug
called movies comma HTTP status
dot okay.
Yeah, let's take a look at our
repository. Once again, it's all
set up.
Services fine, the controller is
fine. Let's cross our fingers
and see if this works or not.
Going to go back to our browser
and hit refresh.
And the reason behind this
problem lies in my EMV file. So
as you can see,
we have called our database
movie API dB.
But in our configuration, we
mistakenly put an S right here.
So we'll get rid of the s.
Res restart the application and
hope for the best.
And yeah, it works. As you can
see, there are 10 movies in this
list. Since it starts at zero
and ends at nine. There are 10
movies in this list and the code
is perfectly fine. Now let's go
back to the code and let me re
iterate on what we have done so
far. So in rest API's, usually
there are multiple layers. So
one of the layers is the API
layer, which is this controller
and it will only concern itself
have about the task of getting a
request from the user and
returning a response and nothing
else. And that's what it's
doing. All it's doing is it's
using a service class and
delegating the task of fetching
all the movies from the
database. And give me giving it
back to the API layer. So it
calls the all movies method
inside
the service, gets the list of
the movie and returns them with
HTTP status. Okay, it doesn't
know what's going on inside the
service class. Now, when we come
back to the service class, this
is where most of our business
logic will go.
For now, there is nothing to be
worried about in this classes.
But soon, we will work with a
little bit more complex business
logic in this API. So the
service class does is it uses
the repository class, and talks
to the database, get the list of
the movies and returns to the
API layer. Finally, the
repository layer is kind of the
data access layer for our API II
does the job of actually talking
to the database and getting the
data back.
I hope that makes sense. Now,
since we have a list of all the
movies in our databases, let's
complicate it a bit more by
trying to access a single movie.
Now, we will begin by creating a
new get mapping.
And that is
get mapping and this will
actually take an parameter.
And we will have this a slash
that inside a pair of curly
braces will say ID. So we are
trying to search a movie by its
ID.
So we can set public
response entity. This time, we
will return a single movie.
And we'll say get single
movie. Sorry for the type book.
We'll close
the pair of parentheses
and we'll start our method.
Now inside the pair of
parentheses, we'll have to say
PATH variable, which lets the
framework know that we will be
passing the information we got
in the mapping as a path
variable. Or we will be using
the information passed in the
PATH variable
as a string,
or just object.
Id ID.
So what this does is it lets the
framework know that whatever we
are getting through this path
variable, we want to convert
that to an object ID called ID.
And then we can say
return first we'll have to go
back to our service layer and
write a new method here.
Public
movie single movie
and we will say return
movie repository dot
find by ID
and we will get that ID right
here.
And it goes here it
David and the squiggly line it
says that whichever option okay?
So the thing here is that the
find by ID method may not find
any movie at all, maybe the ID
you have passed doesn't exist.
So in those cases, you it will
have to return now, so we'll
have to let Java know that it
may return null by saying
optional
movie
and we will just import the
optional class
we will also have to fix our
response entity movie will say
optional.
Movie
optional has been imported nice
and then
We can say return new response
entity
optional
movie. And inside there we can
say movie service
dot single movie, we will pass
the ID that we have received
comma
HTTP status dot. Okay.
Let's restart the application
let's go to our MongoDB compass
inside the movie collection and
copy one of the object IDs right
here let's copy
for Roald Dahl's Matilda the
musical. Let's copy the object
Id
go back to our browser.
And we can say movies, slash and
then the object ID.
As you can see, we have found
Roald Dahl's Matilda the
musical. Now, the problem is
that I do not want to expose the
object IDs of my collection
entities to the public. Instead,
what I want to do is use this
IMDb ID to search for new
movies.
So let's see if we can find a
way to do that.
Now although the repository
comes with built in methods for
searching with ID, it doesn't
come with methods for searching
with IMDb ID so what we'll have
to do is we'll have to implement
that method ourselves. And it's
really easy because there is
something called automatic
queries that lets you
farm where it is dynamically
from.
property names so we will say
optional.
Movie because it may return null
once again, we'll have the input
optional
movie and we will call it
find movie
by
in dB ID and it takes a string
I am DB ID.
Now just by naming this method
find movie by IMDb ID
MongoDB data Spring Data MongoDB
will understand what we are
trying to do. It's that much
intelligent. So now we can go
back to our service class.
We are no longer getting an
object ID but we are getting a
string
IMDb ID
and instead of find by ID we
will say
find a movie by IMDb ID, IMDb ID
and that's it.
Let's go back to controller.
We'll change this from ID to
IMDb ID by the way you do not
have to name the ID IMDb ID
exactly in this method. It's
It's just that I know what I'm
doing in a later date. So we
will replace object ID by string
IMDb ID
and then response entity
optional movie. This is fine.
Yeah IMDB.
So technically, this should do
our job. Let's check it out
let's see seems like there has
been a mistake.
Let's go up
it looks like there is a
problem. Let's go back to
our movie repository.
And the music
It is it should be IMDb and not
IMBD. So as you can see, the
framework is clever enough to
see that I have misspelled
the property name right here.
So let's run the program once
again and see if you're trans or
not
fine tuned by cannot find
up here, I have to correct
terrorism,
DIA. And yeah, it shouldn't be
fine
let's go back to our browser.
And as you can see API slash var
slash movies. And then I have
used the IMDB ID for this movie.
Hit enter, and it works just
fine. We can use the IMDB ID to
search for movies.
Now, you can actually form
dynamic queries like this using
any property name in your model
class.
As long as they're unique,
because if that's not unique,
you will get multiple
movies with the same ID or same
name. Okay.
Now that we have our movie
controller sorted out, let's
start working on our review
controller, where we will let
the user send us review. And we
will add those under a movie
name.
So let's first create a new
repository.
View
posit Ori
and it spends Mongo D. B,
Mongo repository and the die
will be revealed.
And object ID is our type. Yeah,
yeah, that's their
next let's create a new service
class. Oh, I almost forget to
enter this as repository.
So, create a new class called
the views service.
And this will be a service
class. So I'll go service
here I will say public
then
this method will create a new
reviews so it will return a new
review then here she view
by
creative
then this method will take two
parameters. The first one will
be a string
which will be the reveal body
and the since
the second one will be string
IMDb ID so what we are trying to
do here we will first look for
the movie with the given IMDb
ID. And then we will create a
new review and associate that
review with the found movie. So
let's first create a new review.
Review
few quotes from new review.
Now you may
now you may remember that in the
review class, we have an pol
arcs constructor and an aurochs
constructor. But since IDs are
auto generated, we cannot pass
an ID to this class. So what we
will do we will also generate a
custom constructor that takes
only the body. Now in IntelliJ
IDEA you can right click inside
a class go to generate and then
constructor and we only need the
body part of this class. So
that's
now let's go back to our service
class and new review and we will
pass the review body
Excellent.
Now that we have a new review,
we will have to associate these
to one of the movies
now that we have a new review
object, we will have to insert
it to the database and for
After that, we will need
a reference to our
review repository.
So review repository view
repository and needs to be auto.
Fine. And we will say,
review repository
dot insert, and review.
X. And that's the review taken
care of now we can have to
associate with this with one of
the movies, right? To do that,
we
need a few things. Now the first
thing that we need is called a
template to create a template
with set private Mongo template,
Mongo template. Now, you have
already learned about
repositories as one of the ways
to talk to the database. The
other way is using a template.
You see there are times when a
repository just doesn't cut it,
maybe you have an operations so
complex that it cannot be
implemented within a repository,
or even if you can implement it
within a repository, it will be
not
suitable. So what we need, we
need a
template, you can use this
template to form up a new
dynamic query and do the job
inside the database without
using the repository. So we will
alter this.
And then down here, we will say
Mongo template
dot update, since it's an update
operation, and we need to say
which class to you do we want to
update. So we want to update all
of the movies.
And then come to the second line
and put a dot here. And then as
you can see, there are multiple
operations that we can perform.
So we want the match.
Now inside the matching of
version, we will need a new
criteria. So we'll set criteria
dot fire.
And inside where we will say
IMDb ID, make sure it's matching
up with the column name or the
property name inside the
database
then.is the IMDB ID that we have
got.
Then come to the next line and
put a dot once again and then
we'll say Apply.
We'll say new update. This is
called an update definition
dot push
review IDs
and then dot
value
sheet view.
See, that's pretty much it.
Okay, so what we are doing is we
are using the template to
perform an update call on the
movie class. Because I hope that
you'll remember that each movie
in our collection contains an
empty array of review IDs. So
what we need to do,
what we need to do is we need to
update this array and push a new
review ID into this.
So we are saying movie dot class
then we have to perform the
matching. So which movie are you
updating? We are updating a
movie where the IMDB ID of the
movie in the database matches
the IMDB ID that we have
received from the user. Okay,
then we want to apply this
update. To do so we call apply.
And then we create a new update
definition which does the job of
making the change inside the
database. So we say Update, push
and review IDs. So we want to
update the review IDs in this
found movie and the value of
this movie will be revealed. So
that review that we have just
created it will be pushed inside
the review IDs array okay.
Now, finally, we will have see
the
First, to make sure that we are
getting a single movie and we
are updating that. Now one thing
that I have done, which I
shouldn't have is we cannot new
up a review like this.
Rather, what we need to do is we
will just save the review on
insert, because when you call
insert, it actually returns the
data you just pushed inside your
database. Okay?
First, finally, we can return
that view we just created.
So let's review the Create
review method. We are taking a
new Mongo template, we are using
it to update the movie with the
new review, we just pushed using
the repository.
So likely say sometimes you will
have to code up complex business
logics by yourself. And as you
grow as a software engineer and
an web developer, you will start
to understand all these things
all by yourself.
So let's go back to our review
service. Yeah. So I mean, our
review
is is fine. If you're in
positions where you feel
service, yeah. Now let's create
a new review controller.
And inside this controller, we
will have only one post method.
But you may think, why only a
single post method? How are we
going to get all these reviews
that are associated with a
movie, I'll show you how.
Now let's begin by annotating it
as a Rest Controller.
And then of course, we will have
input request mapping
which is
slash API slash v1 slash
mobile movies
Okay, since
the review form will be inside a
movies Details page, or in the
page where you are viewing a
single movie so we can make the
requests to the movies and point
instead of creating a new if we
use NS N bar. Now when it comes
to creating endpoints like this,
it really depends on the on the
developers preferences, you may
you may choose to organize your
API differently from what I am
doing here. And in a real life
project I maybe I will do
something different but since
it's just for learning, and we
are just getting started, I
think it's fine.
Inside the controller, we'll
first need our service. So we'll
say private
reveal Service Review service
and we will auto add this
nice
then we'll create a new post
mapping
and then a new method of Lake
will again return a response
entity and this will be of type
review. And we will call it
create review method.
Inside this pair of parentheses
we will say
request body
then map
string, comma string
and we will call it payload
so we'll import map.
So, what we are saying to the
framework here that whatever we
get as the request body we would
like to convert it to a map of
the key string and value string
and we want to name this map as
payload you will see why this is
then we will say
return new response entity.
And yeah we can say review this
review
and then it says Service Review
service dot create review and we
will pass two tests. First one
payload dot get
is the review body
and the second one will be
payload
Don't get
IMDb ID Okay.
Finally we say
comma
HTT be
status dot created, it will be
201. Since we are creating a new
review, we want to send 201
instead of the plane 200 Because
this means created and that
means okay. So now that we have
the post mapping done, we need
our REST client a separate risk
flying to test our test out our
code. But before that, I can see
that there is this squiggly line
underneath the view controller.
So I will just go to problems
and see what's wrong. cannot
resolve symbol IMDb ID Okay,
let's see where I missed a typo
here. So it should be inside a
pair of quotation mark. And
that's gone. See, this is the
beauty of IntelliJ IDEA. It
helps you a lot. Now let's
restart our program. And I will
use postman to test out our API.
In fact, I just thought instead
of mapping the reviews request
to API slash API slash movies,
let's just go with reviews.
Because that sounds more
appropriate. Now let's start our
application
and let's jump to postman.
So inside postman first, I'll
create a new collection. And
I'll call the movies API.
Then let's create a new GET
request get all movies
so it would be localhost 8080
slash API slash VLANs slash x.
So it works out just fine. Let's
copy the IMDB ID from one of
these movies so that we can test
out our next request
which will be
get a single movie
and we should be able to carry
everything from the previous
request
will host slash view and slash
movies slash then the IMDB ID.
Let's execute and the works just
fine.
Finally, let's try to create a
new review here to review.
And let's say v1 slash reviews.
Okay, that's I set that because
by mistake so it has to be post
inside body I would say raw data
in JSON format.
So I will say review
body will be I really enjoyed
the movie with
I.
Yeah. And then I will say IMDb
ID,
column and timed ID. Now you
have to make sure that the name
or the key in this JSON data
review body and IMDb ID
exactly matches the two keys
inside the payload which is
review body and IMDb ID. So what
will happen is this endpoint
will receive a JSON data from
the user and then convert it to
a map where the keys are extreme
and the values are history. Then
from this map, we'll be able to
access the review body which is
a string and the IMDB ID, which
is another string. And then
through the service layer, we
can create a new review on the
database, update the movie to be
associated with that review, and
then return the review. And of
course, there's a repository
that works as the intermediary
layer
between the service class and
the database to let's let's go
let's come back
postman, and let's see if it
actually works on
here. So we have got 201
created. So theoretically, we
should have created a new review
for the movie boosting boards.
And let's go back to get a
single movie it sent,
come down to review ideas. And
of course, we have the new
review associated with this
movie.
That's how we can get the list
of review ideas, they will be
embedded with the data of the
movie they're referred to.
So in terms of the API, that's
it, I know, it's a pretty simple
API. But the goal of this
course, or the first half of
this course, was to give you
some idea about how you can
create a new back end API.
Powered by Spring Boot and
MongoDB. I hope that you have
understood the basic concepts.
using MongoDB. And Spring Boot
together, you can go ahead and
further your study by learning
about how to implement
authorization and
authentication. You can also
learn about more complex
relationships, and maybe try to
build a bigger API with Gillette
and ports and other kinds of
requests. I will be leaving this
stretch right now. And from now
on Gavin long will teach you how
you can create a React
application that can go with
this API. So take care, I will
maybe see you in another course
in the future. Now that you've
learned how to develop the back
end, Gavin will teach you how to
develop the front end using
React. Just a quick note before
we get started, this will not be
a deep dive into React. My only
goal here is to demonstrate how
we can interface with a remote
API from a front end application
created using React through
which we are able to retrieve
data from a MongoDB database
hosted on a remote server, as
well as posting data to our
MongoDB database. Now, any data
that we retrieve from the server
will be in JSON format. JSON
formatted data may be pleasing
to some people. But most users
of application I think would
much prefer something like this.
So we're going to transform the
data passed to us in a JSON
format into an aesthetically
pleasing front end display.
React and associated
technologies provide an
efficient way to create both
aesthetically pleasing front
ends, as well as help us
developers to facilitate a great
UX user experience. I'd like to
give a shout out to the movie
db.org All the movie poster
images and backdrop images that
we are going to use in the React
application that we are going to
build in this course, come from
the movie db.org Right, let's
get into it. Let's start by
launching VS code.
And let's create a working
folder on our local machines.
I'm going to name my folder
movie client.
Let's open our working folder
like this from within VS code.
So we are going to use the
Create dash react dash app
command to generate our React
projects infrastructure. You of
course, must have Node js,
preferably the latest version
installed on your local machine
as a prerequisite before
creating a React application.
If you don't have no JS
installed, you can navigate to
this URL to install the latest
release of node j s. So from
within VS code, let's launch the
terminal window so that we can
create our React project
infrastructure using the Create
dash react dash app command.
You can launch the terminal
window from within VS code by
pressing Ctrl and the tilde
character.
Great.
So the current directory
reflected at the terminal prompt
should be the working directory
that we have just created. my
working directory is named movie
client.
Then at the terminal prompt,
let's type in MPX space create
dash react dash app followed by
the name we'd like to call our
React project. So I'm going to
name my react project movie dash
gold dash v one
Then let's press the enter key.
And the Create dash react dash
app command generates the React
project infrastructure, which
includes all the relevant node
modules that contain components
that we are able to import into
our React application. This
process can take a while to
complete.
And we can see the process on my
local machine has now completed.
So at this stage, we don't
really need the movie client
folder. Opened within VS code,
we only want the folder
containing the files for our
React project. So at the
terminal, let's use the cd
command and then enter the name
of the React application that we
created using create dash react
dash app. So I'm going to type
cd space movie dash gold dash v
one, and press the Enter key. So
once we have made the folder
containing the files for our
React projects infrastructure,
we can launch another instance
of VS code by typing and code
space dot and then pressing the
Enter key. This command opens
another instance of VS code,
where we are now directly within
the folder that contains the
files for our React projects
infrastructure.
We can now close down the first
instance of VS code, because we
only need the instance that we
have just launched.
So we are almost ready to create
our React application.
We won't be using some of the
files that the Create dash react
dash app commands generated for
us. So let's delete the
following files from within the
SRC directory. Let's delete the
setup tests dot j s file, the
report vitals dot j s file and
the app dot test dot j s file.
We must also delete a setting
from within the package dot json
file, which has to do with
linting. We don't need this
linting setting in our project.
Let's save our changes.
Lastly, let's open the index.js
file and remove the code related
to the report web vitals
functionality like this.
Let's save our changes
and let's move on to installing
a few NPM packages that contain
components that we are going to
integrate into our application.
If your project terminal is not
available within VS code at the
moment, you're able to launch
the terminal by pressing Ctrl
and the tilde character.
The next package we are going to
install is Axios Axios will make
it easy for us to make HTTP
requests from our React client
to the relevant API hosted on a
distant remote machine. So that
we can retrieve relevant movie
data from the MongoDB database
also hosted on the relevant
distant remote machine through
HTTP GET requests.
We will also be able to add
movie reviews to the relevant
Mongo DB database through the
use of HTTP POST request, which
will be facilitated on our React
client through the use of Axios.
We'll implement this
functionality later in this
video.
So to install Axios, we can type
this command at the command
prompt NPM space install space
Axios.
And let's press the enter key.
Great, so let's install our next
NPM package
which will enable us to use
Bootstrap for layout and styling
purposes from within our React
project. So let's type the
following at our command prompt
NPM space install space
Bootstrap.
Note that in order to integrate
bootstrap into our project, we
must include this import
statement within the index.js
file.
Let's save our changes.
The next NPM package that we
must install
allows us to use Bootstrap
related components for layout
and styling purposes. So let's
install react dash Bootstrap.
For this purpose, we can install
react dash bootstrap by typing
NPM space I space react dash
Bootstrap.
And of course, follow this by
pressing the Enter key.
Great. The next NPM package that
we are going to install enables
us to easily install font
awesome icons within our React
application. The first font
awesome related package can be
installed by typing in npm space
I space at Fort dash awesome,
forward slash react dash Font
Awesome.
So make sure you type at Fort
dash awesome here and not at
font stash awesome, which I know
is a little bit confusing. So
it's add 14 Awesome dash, react
dash and then Font Awesome.
Great.
Let's install the second font or
some related package by typing
in npm space I space at Fort
Awesome forward slash free dash
solid dash SVG dash icons.
And let's Of course, press the
enter key.
Excellent.
To play movie trailers from
within our application, we're
going to use the React player
component. So let's install the
appropriate NPM package. So that
we can integrate react player
into our React application. So
let's type npm space I space
react dash player
and press the Enter key.
Great in order to declare the
paths where our components will
reside, in order to map the
routes to our components as it
were, we are going to use
relevant components from the
React dash router dash DOM NPM
package. So in order to install
the React dash router, dash DOM
NPM package, let's type in this
command npm space I space react
dash router dash DOM.
And of course, press the enter
key.
Great.
On our homepage, we want to
display relevant movies in a
carousel.
We can easily implement a
carousel using material UI. So
in order to do this, we must
install three material UI NPM
packages. So we can install the
relevant three NPM packages by
typing the following NPM space
install space at Nui forward
slash material space at emotion
forward slash react space at
emotion forward slash styles.
And let's press the enter key.
Excellent.
In order to use the material UI
carousel component, let's
install the material UI carousel
NPM package. We can do this by
typing in npm space install
space react dash material, dash
UI dash carousel
and press the Enter key.
Great,
and we have now installed all
the NPM packages we need in
order to integrate the
functionality we want to include
within our React application.
Excellent. Let's get started
with writing the code for our
React application. So the first
thing I'd like to do is set up
Axios. So to do this, let's
create a folder within the src
folder
and
Let's name our folder API.
Let's create a file within the
API folder named Axios config
dot j s.
We can import Axios into our
project with this line of code.
So we can configure and export
the Axios object that we will
use to make HTTP requests to the
relevant remote API through this
code.
Notes the settings that have
been included here,
we have the base URL setting,
which provides the base address
of the API endpoints that our
client react application will be
calling. So you'll see later on
when we use Axios. To call an
endpoint, we won't need to
repeat the base URL with each
HTTP request within our code, we
will only need to include the
additional path information
required to target a specific
endpoint. If this isn't clear,
at the moment, it will become
clear. When we write code to
make a HTTP request to the
relevant remote endpoint. This
setting here is necessary.
Because during the development
phase, the technology that the
remote machine is using to
expose the relevant API
endpoints is called ngrok.
I won't go into the specifics of
N grok. But we need to include
this setting in order for our
client HTTP requests to not be
blocked by cause I won't go into
the details, of course, but it
stands for cross origin resource
sharing. So all we need to know
is that because the relevant web
API is running in a different
domain, or origin, that cause
may block our access to the end
point. The server code has
included settings in order to
overcome the restrictions
imposed by cores. And we are
including this setting in the
HTTP headers of our requests
from the client, so that we can
overcome the restrictions
imposed by cause IE, so that we
are able to access the resources
made available through the
relevant API endpoints. Great,
so we have now set up Axios.
Let's open the app.js file and
write code to call an endpoint
that will return an array of
movie data.
Let's write code to import our
Axios object from within our
Axios config.js file.
Let's import the use state hook
and the use effect hook from
react.
Let's return a D structured
array from the use state hook.
The first item in the de
structured array is named movies
and will store an array of movie
data returned from a call to the
relevant API endpoint.
The second item in the array is
a function that can be used to
change the state of the movies
variable.
When the state of the variable
tracked by react through the use
state hook is changed the
component is re rendered by
react. So in this case, the app
component will be re rendered
when the state of the movies
variable changes. Let's create a
function that will handle a HTTP
get request to an endpoint that
returns an array of movie data.
Once the movie data is
successfully returned, this code
that changes the state of the
movies array is executed.
You can see here we are passing
the additional path information
to the get method. This path
information is appended to the
base URL setting that we created
when setting up the
configuration for Axios.
We are using async await for
asynchronous thread management
functionality
to the client, I won't go into
detail explaining async await
and promises. But this
functionality can be effective
in ensuring that the UI is not
blocked. When potentially long
running operations, like for
example, a remote API call are
processed, the UI thread will
not be blocked, and therefore
the use of screen will not, for
example, freeze, the use the
screen will still be responsive,
while a potentially long running
IO bound operation is
processing. Once the relevant
task has completed, the code
directly below the code that
kicks off the awaited process
will be executed. So it's like a
promises made to return to the
appropriate line of code. Once
the task potentially long
running IO bound task, for
example, has completed.
As explained, this async await
functionality is useful in order
to ensure a better UX user
experience. In case something
goes wrong during the execution
of our HTTP request, let's wrap
the relevant code in a try catch
block. And let's include code in
the catch block to log the
relevant exception to the
browser console window. So you
could be more thorough here in
your code and check the HTTP
status code. For example, if the
HTTP status code returned from
the server is 200. This
indicates that the operation
performed on the server was
successful.
I'm not going to include this
functionality in this course, in
order to keep the code fairly
basic for our HTTP requests that
we are executing from the
client.
Let's implement the use effect
hook so that the get movies
function is executed when the
app component first loads.
Let's also write code to log the
results returned from the call
to the relevant endpoint to the
browser console window.
Let's use the npm start command
to run our React application.
Let's look at the browser
console window to see if our
results have been returned from
the server.
Excellent our HTTP get request
made through the use of Axios
executed successfully.
So the next step is to start
implementing our routing
functionality or routing
functionality.
Let's create a React component
named layout dots Jas.
Let's open the layout.js file
and import the outlet component
from the React Router DOM NPM
package to generate boilerplate
code for our layout component,
we can type ra F C E and press
the Tab key like this.
Let's rather use semantic HTML
here and include main tags
instead of div tags. Within our
main tags, let's include a
reference to the outlet
component.
Let's go back to the app.js file
and write code to import the
layout component that we have
just created.
Right, so I'm going to create a
components folder within the src
folder, and move the layout.js
file into the components folder.
Let's write the code to import
the layout component into the
app component.
Let's write code to import the
routes component and the route
component from the React Router
DOM NPM package
in the return part of the app
component, ie where JSX code is
returned from our component,
let's write code to establish
the route mappings as it were
for our applications React
components. So let's first add
the routes.
elements here
within the root element, let's
include a parent root element.
It's a parent root element
because child root elements will
be included within this parent
root element. Like, for example,
a child route component that
points to the home component we
will write the home component in
a bit, will be a child of the
parent route component that
points to the layout component.
So the layout component
referenced through the outlet
element in the layout.js file
denotes the components pointed
to by the child root component
references that will include
within the parent root element
here, we'll include the relevant
child root elements as we
progress with the development of
our React application. The next
step is to open the index.js
file and write code to import
the browser router component,
the routes component and the
route component into the index
component.
Let's include code to establish
the relevant route mapping for
the app component.
Great, let's create our home
component. Let's first create a
folder within the components
folder named home. Let's ensure
that the first letter in our
home folder name is lowercase.
Let's add a file named home with
an uppercase H to our home
folder. Let's type in ra f c e
followed by pressing the tab key
to generate boilerplate code for
the home component.
Let's simply type in the text
welcome so that we can test our
route functionality.
We'll create the code for our
home component in just a bit
let's create the code for the
route element that points to our
home component within the app.js
file.
Oops, I can see a little bug in
our code. This reference to
layout
is not correctly formed. Let's
include the layout element
properly within our code here.
Let's type in npm. Start at our
command prompt and press Enter
to launch the application
Great.
So let's create a component that
will be a child component of the
home component. We will name
this component hero. This
components denotes the hero
section of our home page that
will display items in a carousel
that are representative of
movies to the users of this
application. So let's create a
folder within the components
folder named hero.
Within the hero folder, let's
add a file named hero dot j s.
Let's also add a file to the
hero folder named hero dot css
where we will of course include
CSS code for our hero component.
Let's write code to import the
hero dot css file into our hero
component.
Let's import the carousel
component from the relevant man
Terrio UI NPM package
let's import the paper component
from the relevant material UI
NPM package
let's write code to destructure.
The props passed into this
component, only one destructured
value containing an array of
movie data needs to be included
here
let's implement the carousel
functionality. Let's include the
carousel element like this.
Within the carousel element,
let's write code to map each
item in the movies array to an
item displayed in the carousel.
The pay per element encapsulates
each movie item displayed in the
carousel.
Let's include div tags, so that
the movie poster is displayed,
as well as the movie title is
displayed for each carousel
item.
As you can see, I've included
CSS class references in the
relevant div tags, we'll style
our components in the hero dot
css file in a bit,
where we will implement the
appropriate CSS properties for
these CSS classes.
Oops, let's make sure that we
are importing the hero dot css
class correctly here.
Let's open the home.js file and
include the hero element in the
part of the code that is
returned as JSX code from the
home component.
Let's make sure that we are
importing the hero component
into our home component.
Let's write code to ensure that
the movies array is being passed
down from the app component to
the home component and
subsequently the hero component.
And that's great. We are
displaying the relevant data
from the JSON data returned from
the relevant API's endpoint. But
let's customize the styling of
our carousel through CSS code.
We can position our Vyas code
editors to a pane on the left
side of our screens. And we can
position our browsers to a pane
on the right side of our screens
like this. In this way, we can
watch the effects of our CSS
code changes in real time. I'm
not going to go into a lot of
detail regarding the CSS code.
The code will be available on
GitHub, where you can examine it
in more detail if you'd like.
Let's first update the CSS code
in the app dot css file. This
CSS code effects all components
that are child components of the
app component.
And you're able to observe the
effects of the CSS code on the
browser in real time as the CSS
code evolves.
So let's import
quicksand font from Google with
this line of code
let's set up the box sizing and
font family properties for all
elements
let's set the body elements
padding and margin properties to
zero.
Let's style the App class. Note
that all of our components are
children of the app component.
Let's remove this code from the
index dot css file because it is
not needed
let's style the carousel
component that has been
implemented within our hero
component. So let's include our
CSS code in the hero dot css
file.
And we are able to watch the
effects on the carousel
displayed in our browsers in
real time as the relevant CSS
code evolves.
And we don't actually want the
post image to take up the
carousel display. As it is at
the moment, we want an
appropriate backdrop image a
larger image to fill the
background for each item in the
carousel.
I want to include a gradient
that fades from dark to light
from the bottom of each carousel
item to where the title is
displayed. In order to
dynamically reference the
background image URL for each
carousel card,
I'm going to use a CSS custom
variable.
So we can do this by including
an inline style within the div
element that references the
movie dash card CSS class. And
within that inline style, assign
a variable to the property that
we wish to reference within the
relevant CSS file. So here, we
are naming our custom CSS
variable image.
We are setting the CSS URL value
to the CSS background dash image
CSS property from the backdrops
property of each movie in the
movies array returned from the
server. Note that the backdrops
property returned from the
server is an array containing
pause to movie backdrop images.
In this code, I'm choosing to
reference the first backdrop
image path in the backdrops
array returned from the server.
Each backdrop points to an image
that we want displayed as a
background image appropriately
for each movie item in the
carousel. We can now reference
each background image from
within our CSS class and style
the background appropriately.
So we are assigning the
background dash image CSS
property or gradient that fades
from light to dark?
This is just a stylistic choice.
For our front end display, you
can see here in our CSS code how
we are using the dash dash image
custom CSS variable to link the
URL property value referenced in
the JSX code in the hero
component to the background dash
image CSS property in the hero
dot css file. You can see that
the poster image is looking
distorted so let's style the
poster and the title
appropriately.
Great and we have used absolute
positioning and the CSS Flexbox
to style our poster and handle
where it appears in the layout
let's style the title
appropriately.
Great, and our carousel is
looking pretty good. Let's
create the components to house
our navigation display. Let's
create the header component. So
let's create a folder within the
components folder named header.
Let's create a file within the
header folder named header.js.
Let's import the appropriate
font awesome components
let's import the appropriate
bootstrap components.
And let's use React bootstrap
components to create a
responsive layout for our
navigation menu which will be
displayed at the top of the
screen. This is one of the huge
advantages of using Bootstrap it
can save us a lot of time in
creating responsive layouts.
We are using the FA video flash
font awesome icon for our logo
that will be displayed in the
top left corner of our screen
within the navigation bar that
we are creating within the
header component.
The login and registration
buttons are being included here.
Superficially, they are purely
cosmetic indicating that we
could extend the functionality
of this application to include
login and registration
functionality at a later stage.
For example, if we wanted to
enable users to create their own
list of favorite movies or a
watch list, the watch list link
here is also there purely for
cosmetic reasons. We won't
implement a watch list component
in this course.
So above the routes
functionality within the app.js
file, let's reference the header
component
let's go back to the header.js
file and make sure that our
imports are correct.
Let's run the code
Excellent, our navigation bar,
and our logo looks pretty good
the next step is we want to be
able for a user to click a play
button icon on each carousel
item. And for an appropriate
movie trailer to play will
enlist the help of the React
player component for this
purpose. Let's first create a
folder named trailer within the
components folder.
Let's create a file named
trailer dot j s within the
trailer folder. Let's also
create a file named trailer dot
css within the trailer folder.
Let's create the relevant input
code in the trailer.js file.
Let's import the use params hook
into our code from the React
Router DOM NPM package, a
YouTube video ID will be passed
into this component as a
parameter. So we are going to
use the use params hook to
extract the relevant parameter
value from the relevant URL. The
relevant parameter will contain
a YouTube video ID which will
allow us to play a YouTube
video, which is a trailer of the
relevant movie to the user.
Let's import the React player
component.
Let's import the trailer dot css
file.
Let's create the boilerplate
code for our trailer component
by typing in our AFC E and
pressing the tab key. Let's
create a div container in which
our React player components will
reside
let's assign the Paston
parameter value to a const named
key
then we can include the React
player component appropriately
like this
we want the player to include
controls. So here we can set the
controls property to true we can
set the playing property to true
so that the relevant video plays
as soon as the trailer component
loads
and lastly, and most
importantly, we can set the URL
property to the relevant video
on YouTube so we can append the
relevant YouTube video ID stored
in the key const to the base
YouTube address to point react
player to the YouTube video that
will be played within react
player great
let's go to the app.js file and
include the relevant route
information for the trailer
component
notice how we are able to let
React Router DOM know as it were
about the YouTube video ID
parameter then our code within
the trailer component must
access
let's include a play button icon
provided by font awesome within
our carousel.
Okay so the play button icon is
present, but it needs to be
appropriately style
Okay, as it is tiny at the
moment, let's go to the hero dot
css file and style the play
button icon appropriately.
Great, let's include a media
query so that our carousel
adapts to smaller screens
Great, let's go to the trailer
dot css file and create CSS code
so that the React player takes
up 90% of the viewport height.
Lastly, we need to create the
link so when the play button
icon is clicked, that the
trailer component is invoked,
and the appropriate parameters
passed through to the trailer
component.
So the trailer link property
retrieved from the server
contains the entire URL to the
YouTube video, we only want to
pass the ID of the YouTube video
to the trailer component from
the hero component. We can
extract the YouTube video ID by
using the JavaScript substring
method to extract the last 11
characters from the trailer link
property like this
let's run the code.
Excellent. The last component we
need to create is the reviews
component. The reviews component
will enable users to view
reviews from other users as well
as add reviews for movies into
the system, ie, which entails a
HTTP POST request being made.
From our React component to the
relevant remote API endpoints
carrying the review data entered
by the user and the server side
Java code will then save the
review data appropriately to the
MongoDB database. Firstly, let's
create a component named review
form. This component will
contain a form component that
contains a text area control
where the user can enter text
that denotes a movie review. a
submit button will also be
included so that the user can
click this button in order to
submit the user's movie review.
So let's create a folder named
review form.
Let's create a file named review
form dot j s within the review
form folder.
Let's include the code for the
functionality we have just
discussed.
Let's create the reviews
component that will be a parent
component of the review form
child component. Let's create a
folder named reviews.
Let's include a file within the
reviews folder named reviews dot
j s
let's include the appropriate
import code at the top of the
reviews.js file.
Let's generate the appropriate
boilerplate code for the reviews
React component by typing in RFC
E and then pressing the tab key.
Let's use the use ref hook to
reference the text area control
within the review form. Let's
use the use params hook so that
we can extract the movie ID
parameter value from the
relevant URL.
This movie ID is actually the
IMDB ID of the movie that we
have retrieved through the API
call that is made to retrieve
the array of movie data from the
server. The IMDb ID value, of
course, is used to uniquely
identify a specific movie.
So when our component first
loads,
we want to call a method that is
passed in as a prop to our
component in order to retrieve
the appropriate data for the
relevant movie that the user
wishes to review. So we can use
the use effect hook like this
for this purpose.
Let's use React bootstrap
components for example, the row
and col components to create an
appropriate layout for the
reviews component, we want to
display the poster for the
relevant movie in the left part
of the screen and the reviews in
the right part of the screen we
can use the row and col
components appropriately to
achieve this.
Let's include the review form
element here like this.
Let's create a method named add
review and create the relevant
HTTP POST request functionality
for adding a review to the
MongoDB database which resides
on a remote server.
And let's write code to update
the state of the reviews array
on the client side.
optimistically meaning that we
are not using data returned from
the server ie data that is saved
to the database for updating the
state of the reviews array. We
are updating the array
directly from the data entered
on the client.
We also want to include code
that clears the relevant text
area control. Once the user has
successfully submitted a review,
we are updating the state of the
reviews array on the client
through the use of the set
reviews method that will be
passed as a prop from the app
component.
Let's go to the app.js file and
create a method that uses Axios
to make a get request for data
pertaining to a single movie
so an IMDB ID value will be
passed into this method to the
movie ID parameter and HTTP get
request. Using the movie ID
value appropriately in the URL
will be made to retrieve data
for a single movie from the
remote server.
So let's set the state for the
movie variable.
And to make our code clearer,
let's extract the reviews array
from the movie data and track
the state of the reviews array.
Let's make sure that the
appropriate props are being
passed down to the reviews
component.
We are now able to create
reviews for the movies retrieved
from the remote server
ultimately from a MongoDB
database that stores our movie
data. So we are adding reviews
to our MongoDB database through
an appropriate HTTP POST request
to inappropriate endpoint
Excellent.
One thing we must do whenever we
implement a list of uniquely
identifiable AI
items in our JSX code like this
is appropriately includes the
key property for each list item.
to uniquely identify each item
in the carousel, we can set the
key property for each movie item
displayed within the carousel to
the appropriate IMDb ID value
for each movie. This value has
been passed down to us with the
movie data array that we
retrieved from the remote server
using the appropriate HTTP get
request. I hope you've enjoyed
building this front end using
React. And I hope you feel that
you have benefited from this
course.
If you've got to the end of this
course you've done exceptionally
well. Thank you and take care